why do people want your product you know
what's really about your product that
would resonate with the user who are
your segment what problem
are you solving you know and i think
it's really understanding those pieces
before you can even come up with
a strategy around how do you get your
product in their hands
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring upward labs and hillel at
stanford
hello decentralization welcome
simakinder johnson the co-founder and
ceo of nuggets
an award-winning decentralized
self-sovereign identity and payment
platform
that offers exceptional protection for
customer data as well as a frictionless
customer experience
in 2020 sema won deutsche bank's female
fenty competition
and women in payments unicorn challenge
she was awarded the booking.com
technology playmaker entrepreneur of the
year
and listed as one of the most
influential women in payments
simakinda johnson thank you for joining
me all the way from london how are you
very good thank you for having me
michael i am
incredibly excited to talk about
decentralization to talk about fintech
and to talk about you know your go to
market
you know you know um expertise
with over 20 years of experience working
for phenomenal companies like skype and
microsoft
and so many others you're the winner of
multiple fantastic
awards from deutsche bank to booking and
uh and really amazing stuff but even
more than that i'm excited to start out
with talking about your your path as a
clinical hypno therapist how does that
what does that even mean
yeah clinical hypnotherapist so let me
just tell you a little bit about how
i've started so
yeah that came at a particular time in
my journey after i had my first child
and i thought
i need to put the tech business behind
me uh maybe i could become a clinical
hypnotherapist i'd
seen the power of the mind and i thought
that's
amazing what you can do if you really
believe in something
so yeah i started on that journey but
essentially i
started my career as a production
coordinator working for a tech company
and then just progressed throughout
running
more and more complicated projects i
would say going to the next
exciting project and then i found my
found myself at skype and at microsoft
heading up go to market for them
and then the clinical hypnotherapy i
suppose has helped me throughout that
journey
wow so you're starting out so i mean
that path where you
you know say okay i'm gonna take a
little break i'm gonna i'm gonna explore
that
and you come back into tech but before
we even talk about you know your
path now for decentralization and you
know fentic and really thinking about
okay what is the consumer going how is
the consumer going to interact with
financial institutions in the future
take me back to your days with skype and
microsoft and you're working on go to
market and marketing
what was that all about yeah no
absolutely so look my role was all about
go to market so we
you know commercializing products in
different
markets so that could be an emerging
market for us
it could be a more established market
but it was all around
um getting users to download the product
understand the utility of a product
you know increase frequency of use of a
product
so i had a lot of experience essentially
in customer acquisition
channel strategy um ensuring that
customers are using the product you know
really adding to that frequency of use
and creating that stickiness
within the products but my experience
was definitely more on the b2c
side versus the b to b to c one that i
found myself in today
right so tell me a little bit about your
your experience with the b2c so you're
looking at
at a platform like skype but now you
know it doesn't have to be necessarily
skype but this idea
how do you even approach you know
thinking strategically about a global
brand of go to market what is sort of
like this thing
this whiteboard that's in front of you
that you have to start painting yeah
absolutely so first
it's all understand like why why do
people want your product
you know what's really about your
product that would resonate with the
user who are your segment
what problem are you solving you know
and i think it's really understanding
those pieces before you can even come up
with
a strategy around how do you get your
product in their hands
you know what's the utility of the
product what problem are we solving and
i think that's really key
first i think with every strategy what
makes your life a lot easier is if
you're plugging
an unmet need or you're doing it in a
more thoughtful
way and i think everything right to
start from there first
and then so you don't just come up with
like a channel plan then you really
understand the user that you're
addressing so what are their needs what
are their wants
where's the gap in the market you know
what are we plugging
and then once you've established that
you find out well where are they
how can we get to those users how can we
share stories so in skype's instance uh
we used to use before everyone talked
about
um uh you know personal stories
uh and that type of narrative it was all
around
personal stories like how can i connect
how can i
you know skype went from a an
appointment
by appointment brand to one that was
used by you know eight to ten of your
friends that you could call whether it
was your family whether it's your
friends
i actually feel a little bit sorry for
skype today because it's not coming up
in the conversations
where zoom is where google is and all of
those sorts of products that we're now
using
you know for video conferencing uh
whereas skype was the real
early pioneer of that it really really
was i have to give a tiny anecdote when
i was in eighth grade i traveled to new
york from my brother's graduation from
university
my class in tel aviv was still meeting
for math and i didn't want to miss my
class so i asked my teacher
to open up his laptop with skype so that
i can skype
in and be a part of that class you know
today we take it for granted that you
know we have zoom for classes but you
know
skype was the go to what was the go-to
for me also you know as an eighth grader
i would skype with my friends all
the time so obviously what you did with
skype worked uh see myself
taking your credit for that those are
not right well
you've done a radical shift so we're
talking about a lot of shifts we're
talking you know from
clinical hypno hypnotherapism and now to
go to market and
now we're moving on to fintech and
decentralization
how do you how do you make those rapid
shifts what is that about
yeah no really good question so look um
it wasn't planned
so i spent my time mostly in tech and
then
had worked at skype microsoft and then
around 2015 i think
my husband had his credit card used
fraudulently online and that really
frustrating process
michael of having to cancel your card
coming to the realization that all of us
have
our personal information plugged across
over 100 online services right
and i think it was at that point we
started to do some digging around and we
thought none of us really own
any of our personal information it's
everywhere there's no way of controlling
it
there's no way of revoking access to it
and that i think for us started this
crazy journey
um and it was at that point in 2016 we
went
that's the problem we're going to solve
we're going to enable
users to be able to take back control of
their data in a really comprehensive way
and help businesses protect their
customer data and i think that for us
was the journey that we started and it
really came from it wasn't so much oh
i'm gonna go from go to market and
marketing
i'm now going to go into fintech or i'm
going to go for voip products
to a fintech product it was more again
the problem that we talked about
originally which is
where everything starts you know there
was this real big problem around data
breaches and no one was really solving
it in a comprehensive way
so again really came from that problem
and that unmet need
and that's how we set up nuggets so it
was less about being in fintech
and decentralization more about trying
to solve a problem
right so can you give me a little bit of
an over overview from your perspective
as to
you know the blockchain world and the
decentralized world that really is your
sort of the solution that you're
employing you're implying in your go-to
market
and so that is how you solve for the
pain point that you just described so
how do you
how do you can you just you know give us
a brief overview of what that industry
is like
and then i would love to do a little bit
of a deeper dive into what nuggets
actually is
and how you're actually going about
making that change yeah no so
um yeah so blockchain what we were
looking at and the only way i can talk
about this was i'm not a self-professed
uh
expert on decentralization or blockchain
but what i do know for us and i'll bring
it back to nuggets which is
um we needed to be able to establish our
product we needed something called zero
knowledge storage
in 2016 is we were looking for technical
solutions around how can we really
enable
so that there is only one private key
holder only one person can have access
to their data
and at the same time my business partner
that also happens to be my husband
started reading a princeton paper
around decentralization and it talked
about the blockchain it talked about
ethereum
and it talked about this brilliant i
suppose architecture
that could enable this zero knowledge
storage it had the immutable ledger that
we need for our transaction record and i
can talk a little bit more about that
it had a high level of encryption and as
we were reading that paper we were just
like
tick tick tick it solves the problem
that we're looking for but not by
itself because it's the way we've then
architected what we've built
so from our perspective even though it
is still a nascent technology from our
perspective
um we were like this actually solves our
problem
from an architecture perspective because
of that real zero knowledge that was
inherent within the blockchain
and that's really the process that then
unfolded and the journey that unfolded
around
so it wasn't so much we you know um
we saw the technology and we thought
okay where could we
where could we enable decentralization
or blockchain actually we had the
problem and it was almost like a perfect
fit for us in a technological
advancement that would allow us to
deliver a product like nuggets for those
reasons
right so can you tell me a little bit
about what the product actually is so
how does this
what is actually the product the
negative product and how does it how do
consumers interact with yeah absolutely
so let me start
from here first i'll start for the
problem that we're solving and then how
we've gone about solving it in the
product
so at nuggets you know we're all about
taking back control of your data we
absolutely believe that personal
information should be owned and
controlled by the person
and that privacy is a fundamental human
right and the way data is stored today
needs a fundamental shift
you've seen the data breaches we've seen
the numbers that are lost to
uh payment fraud and identity fraud i
mean the numbers
are bonkers but also what's happened
alongside all of that and covid has just
exacerbated this is that
consumers and businesses are putting
privacy and security as their number one
priority when they consume
goods and services online so to meet
that
we built a a product it's a
self-sovereign id
and payment platform that wants you on
board as a user
whether again you're a consumer user or
a corporate user
you have four products one is a
self-sovereign a digi a self-sovereign
identity
that essentially self-sovereign means
different things to different people so
just to one pack that means that the
user whether it's a consumer or business
can own and control their own identity
but also
all of the credentials that go alongside
that
and then our payment product allows you
to the ability to pay
with an existing debit or credit card
direct bank account payment
but again without sharing any of that
data
apart from personalization with a
merchant the same product allows you to
log into services
accept a contactless delivery again
without sharing and storing any of that
data and the same for our you can share
documents let's say utility bill i'm on
boarding a business bank account i can
share a utility bill
or other documents but the third party
can't download it so our whole product
is essentially around a user owning
controlling their own data
and it comes together is like a login
payment
and those sorts of use cases to bring it
to life for the consumer
so how do you envision you know the
future you know
with nuggets without nuggets but how do
you imagine like the future of how we
operate you know as obviously like
owners of our own data but you know
part of the issue is that you know we
are the owners until somebody else asks
for it right and in order for you to be
able to provide those services
you need the other you know businesses
to buy into what you're doing right they
need to be part of this
new ecosystem because you're creating a
new decentralized ecosystem
that you need both sides of the market
to be there right you're effectively
creating a new marketplace
yeah really good observation so yeah
nuggets is a beat to be to see
business and i think where others have
really struggled in the identity
and payment spaces is that and the same
for skype right these were
huge huge businesses that required a
network effect
you needed huge marketing budgets to
stay relevant on someone's phone
and to be an everyday use product and so
from our perspective the reason how from
a go to market perspective we're
tackling that very problem
is that we've merged identity and
payment together to make it a frequently
used everyday product because
we believe identity by itself is a bit
of an island
so ours is like a funded identity and
what we do is we enable businesses to
better protect their customer data so
imagine
you're with your bank your bank upgrades
its purse
privacy and security layer on its
platform
it asks you to go through a new
onboarding process
to just upgrade your account and then
your subsequent visits now
are all done by a biometric
authentication there's no more usernames
and passwords
now you call your bank or you call a
call center
there's no possibility of phishing or
social engineering because
they ping your digital identity you
verify it's you they
you know it's them calling you and you
can start the conversation
so everything we do at nuggets is around
enabling businesses
to better protect their customer data
and i think that's really key and part
of our go to market strategy which is
what we're not trying to do
is trying to get millions of users to
download the product
and then enable businesses separately
our go to market is intrinsically linked
to businesses enabling their customers
so does that right it's a life a bit
more for you i
a hundred percent but i think that also
what you're outlining here is you know
you have to you know have the people
want to use and you have to
again create this create this really
really cool marketplace where
the incentives are obviously there right
the vision is there you're
you're helping protect but time is money
resources are money right it's it's hard
to
move the needle especially for
businesses who you know are already
you know have different priorities so
how do you get them to buy into this
idea that you know
where we might offer you a new ecosystem
to sell
more trusted customers but then you're
gonna have to go through some friction
in order to first sign up make it happen
and then you're gonna see some of the
upside later on yeah i think the
businesses that we work with
are already their main priorities this
year if they weren't last year
there's a number of key things one is
they're all trying to go to a data
minimization model we've seen the data
breaches
they're relentless uh 2001 was the worst
data breach
record essentially all on all the other
numbers the previous years
so they're all trying to mitigate the
data breaches and the reputational
damage and the cost of recovery that
comes with that
they're all trying to push down payment
and identity fraud
i mean in the uk alone let me let me
unpack that a bit
um fraud cost the uk a lot alone nearly
200 billion a year
okay that's a huge huge number and a
very big incentive for businesses to
want to change that
also the businesses that we work with
already spend millions on identity
verification whether it's people cost um
or technology costs so actually what
we're finding is the businesses that
we're working with
really want to bring down that fraud
number and want to get faster
better and cheaper results with a more
innovative product
so that's actually been okay because
a lot of the priorities are aligned with
the pain points that nuggets addresses
um and i think the thing is you do have
to hit an organization at the right time
they have to
have been looking at wanting to do some
level of digital transformation
looking at that on boarding journey for
new users
and but we're finding that the incentive
is on the other side of the table like
they're they're trying to resolve this
now
and finally there's a comprehensive
solution that allows to do it
i i think i think that's fantastic and i
think that what you're doing the way
that you're envisioning this and i just
love the fact that you're you know
you're not putting yourself as a
decentralized blockchain expert you're a
go-to-market expert that understands
people's needs you understand what
solutions they could be
that could be valuable to them and then
how do you actually go and approach this
two-sided marketplace in saltwater which
i think is really
is really amazing and sima i i'd love to
use the rest of the time to talk a
little bit about your transitions
because
i think that it is something you know
very inspiring about somebody who's
you know very you know deliberately but
also unintentionally making all these
you know very very brave transitions so
what was it like for you to
you know exit out of your previous you
know roles let's go to market and all of
a sudden enter into the co-founder and
ceo hat
of an industry that you're not really
too into right
yeah no absolutely so look i think for
me
it's all been a journey i think and also
being probably a little bit naive along
the way i had no idea of the big
changes that i was making and i think a
lot of people that make these big
changes
um they're not aware about all the risks
associated
with them you're almost taking a step at
a time so i have
never had an idea when i left my
corporate role
um that what it would be to really you
know
one thing is coming up with an idea and
a pitch deck
it's an entirely different thing putting
your savings in the line you know
everything
on the line and then building a business
especially being very early
with a business and you know using a
nascent technology
so i would say a lot of it for me it
wasn't really and maybe others would say
something
it wasn't like this big foresight that i
thought oh my god we would be at the
right place at the right time when
privacy
and security was needed at this point
nuggets would have that solution i would
say it's been a collection of baby steps
to get to where i am today and to make
that jump from corporate it hasn't been
an easy one
because i think when you're the things
that you know in the corporate world or
working for even a scaler
that's not your startup um it's very
different
the one you know making sure that
payroll is sorted
making sure that every decision can have
these fundamental
you know impacts to your business so i
would say you know
for me it was a it's been a slow journey
but a steady one
and one that i've learned across the
world i didn't have this moment of
clarity where i went
that's exactly what i want to do and and
i would also say to michael i had no
idea what we were taking on
uh and and had i had
i maybe would have been too scared to go
into payments
to go into fintech to go into a very
nice use and nation technology without
coming from those industries
amazing i love it seema thank you so
much for your being so generous with
your time this was wonderful i love your
transitions i love your insights into
the go to market world i love your
insights into the you know the
the pain point that people are are
suffering with today and this innovative
idea behind nuggets and how you actually
go about and conquering that
and envisioning envisioning the future
world before we leave i have to ask you
the most important question which is
three words you would use to describe
yourself oh gosh um well i'm definitely
driven
um because i probably wouldn't be doing
what i'm doing
right now people say that i'm
approachable
um and i believe that because i am i
like to meet people and all of those
things
and i'm passionate about what i do if
i'm not passionate about it then
um i probably wouldn't be able to do
what i do and get up every morning
i love it sima thank you very very much
thank you thank you for
taking your time and stay safe and stay
healthy yeah you too thank you